ام
اهلا بكم بدات في لبنان اعمال المؤتمر
العام لمسيحيي المشرق الذي يعقد لاول مره
لبحث احوال للمسيحيين في العالم العربي
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ابعاد مشكلات المسيحيين العرب واسباب تمام
لها خلال السنوات الماضيه
مدى قدره شعوب المنطقه ظروفها الحاليه على
تحقيق ا على قدر من التعايش مستقبلا
المسيحيون في العالم العربي جزء لا يتجزا
من الحضاره العربيه الاسلاميه
هذا ما تقوله الجغرافيا ويؤكده التاريخ
وبالتالي فهم عرضه كغيره من السكان للتاثر
باي تغييرات تحدث في المنطقه قد يكون
الاثر جماعيا ومثال ذلك ما حدث عند انشاء
دوله اسرائيل حيث استهدف الاحتلال اراضي
الجميع مسلمين ومسيحيين وقد يكون الاثر
خاصا ومثال ذلك ما حدث من تهجير للمسيحيين
في العراق اذن تتعدد الرؤى بشان الاسباب
لكن تتحد الامال بشان امكان تحقيقا على
قدر ممكن من التعايش
يوسف مؤتمر مسيحي المشرق المنعقد في بيروت
بانه الاول من نوعه من حيث المشاركون
والموضوعات المطروحه مناقشات مؤتمر ركزت
على مجمل الحريات الدينيه واوضاع طوائف
الشرق المسيحيه توزيعهم السكان والجغرافي
والظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والهجره
في مجتمعاتهم اضافه ل مشاركتهم في
المؤسسات الحكوميه في دولهم الرئيس
اللبناني قال ان عدد مسيحي المشرق يتضاءل
بسبب العنف في المنطقه والصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي وتداعياته مع وما سماه اهتزاز
الفكره القوميه وتنامي حركات رافضه للاخر
لكنه لفت الانظار ايضا الى ان التحولات
العاصفه في العالم العربي لم تكرس الفكر
الاحادي المطلق في اي بلد ضم التاكيد
المستمر وعلى شراكه المسلمين والمسيحيين
الفلسطينيين
احتلال ارضهم يشكل قلقا متزايدا لسلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وواجه المسيحيون
الفلسطينيون شانهم شان المسلمين سياسات
الاقصاء والتمييز والتهميش والتهجير
المنظم من قبل الاسرائيليين
هم المسيحيين والمسلمين في البلاد العربيه
تكاد تكون واحده واغلبها ليس دينيا وتؤثر
ممارسات الحكم والسياسات الاقتصاديه
واختلال معايير العداله على الجميع ولا
يعني اثرها الواضح احيانا على المسيحيين
انها تستهدفهم شهد العالم العربي مؤخرا
تغييرات جوهريه اهمها الربيع العربي
بافرازاته التي اغلقت بعض الدوائر
المسيحيه
وجعلت كثيرين ينادون بضروره التركيز على
حق المواطنه والمساواه في بناء نظام الحكم
الجديده لكن مسيحي بعض البلدان يواجهون
اتهامات بالاستقواء خارجيا بالغرب لمقاومه
التغييرات في بلدانهم لشيء في انفسهم منها
او الاستقواء داخليا بالانظمه المرفوض
شعبيا
كما في سوريا حيث يتهمون بمسانده نظام
الاسد خوفا من المستقبل وفي كل الاحوال
ياخذ كثيرا على مسيحيي الشرق احكامهم عن
مناقشات همومهم ايا كانت بشكل مباشر بدل
حصرها داخل مجتمعاتهم خاصه من الدول
العربيه جميعها تؤكد انهم كانوا وسيظلون
جزءا اصيبا من الامه العربيه
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفينا من بيروت
الاب الدكتور رشيد ابو خليل استاذ اللغات
الساميه والعلوم الدينيه في الجامعه
اللبنانيه و مع ضيفنا من واشنطن خليل
جهشان الخبير في شؤون الجاليه العربيه في
امريكا اهلا بكما ابن رشيد ما اسباب تنامي
مشكله المسيحيين العرب في هذه الايام
برايك
اه نعم مشكله المسيحيين العرب اه
اختي العزيزه
هي مشكله كل انسان موجود بها ال بها الارض
عم بيعاني الحروب والقتل والقصف اه
والانسان بحاجه يعيش بسلام
يستقر
بها الارض اه لما اه تتوقف الحروب تتوقف
النزاعات اه وحل السلام بقلب ها الانسان
الانسان بيشعر والانسان اللي ترك ارضه
بيقدر يرجع وعيش كرامي بارضه
الداخليه اليوم في المؤتمر الخاص المسيحيه
المشرق الرئيس اللبناني يقال ان ال
المشكله التي تتهدد مسيحيي الشرق هي في
تناقص اعداد هم كانوا خمسه وعشرين بالمائه
اصبحوا سته بالمائه وفي تراجع دور الدوله
في القرار السياسي
والاقتصادي ايضا كما اشار هل تراه كذلك
بالنسبه ل تراجع دور الدوله السياسي
والاقتصادي
اه
انا اعتقد مع هذا التقييم الذي سمعناه في
خطاب اه الرئيس اللبناني اه ولكن في
الواقع هو يغطي جزء من هذه المشكله وليس
المشكله اه ب باكملها يعني اه بدون اي شك
هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر هام ويركز على قضايا
هامه اه بالنسبه للمسيحيين في المشرق
القضايا التي يعانون منها
الجاليات او طوائف مسيحيه ولكن في نفس
الوقت يجب علينا ان لا يعني ننظر الى هذه
المشكله وكانها معزوله عن ما يجري في في
المنطقه المنطقه الان تمر في فتره صعبه في
مطبات اه معقده وصعبه جدا
اجتماعيا وسياسيا واقتصاديا
اه وهذا يؤثر على المجتمع العربي ككل
وبضمنه طبعا اه الاقليات ان كان الاقليات
الدينيه او النساء او غير ذلك من اه
الاقليات الموجوده في بلدان مختلفه اه في
جميع انحاء العالم العربي ولكن يعني بدون
اي شك هذه المشاكل ان كانت ديموغرافيه اه
بالنسبه للهجره خارج الوطن العربي او
بالنسبه ل ال المضايقات وعدم الانتماء
والشعوب اه بعدم الان في الانتماء او
الاقتراب عن اه التيارات السياسيه الطاغيه
الان اه في المجتمعات العربيه
اه كل هذه الظواهر ناجمه عن هذه التغييرات
التي نشاهدها نتيجه الحراك العربي الان
طبعا مع خلفيه تاريخيه لكل من هذه
اولا من المعلوم عنها الكنيسه تتحفظ على
كلمه اقليه في المنطقه مسيحيون عمرهم الفا
عامه في ال في المنطقه وتعايشوا مع
المسلمين حوالي الف واربعمائه عام ما تعلق
على هذه النقطه بالتحديد ان من يسمون
بالاقليات اه من ضمنهم محسوب ال المسيحيون
يشعرون بانه في خضم هذا الحراك العربي في
المنطقه العربيه بانهم معارضون اكثر من
غيرهم الاتهام
نعم اه نحن لا ننظر الى العدد كارقام لانه
العدد
ينمو
ويقل لكن نحن ننظر الى انه المسيحيين هم
اه اصيلون في هذا البلد وهم
المؤسسون لهذا المشرق العربي لانه كان
وجودهن اه بها المشرق الفين سنه وفي مثل
ما قلت لحضرتك
الف واربعمائه سنه مع اخوتهم
المسلمين بها البلد اللي هني اه صنعوا ال
الحضاره الواحده
وساهم ببنائها المجتمع وتعايشوا مع بعضهم
البعض اه نحنا اه منا اقليه اه بالمعنى
انه نحنا ب درجه ثانيه نحنا واصلين
ونحنا عندنا بها البلد اه كرامتنا
وكرامتنا تجي منها العيش المشترك او العيش
الواحد مع
اخوتنا المسلمين بها بها المشرق
والانسان يا اللي بدو سيهم بالسلام هو
الانسان اللي بيكون عم
اذا بدك اه عم بيحقق قيمته لانه ان كان
البيان الاسلاميه هي تابعوا الى الى الى
السلام والعيش مع الاخر
والديني المسيحيه تدعو ايضا الى السلم
والمحبه والعيش مع الاخر لكي معا نبني
سويه هذا ال المجتمع اللي هو غني بال بال
بال بال بال حضاره ويا اللي هو كان عم
يحتوي كثير من ال الشعوب والديانات لكن
الدين المسيحيه والدين الاسلاميه كانوا
هني نموذج
بالعيش الواحد من هيك اه
قداسه البابا اه البابا يوحنا بولس الثاني
اه يا اللي اصبح تربويا وبعد فتره راح
بيصير قد اعلن من لبنان نفسه لانه شايف
نموذج انه لبنان هو اكثر من بلد كيف اكثر
من بلد لانه هو اه ملتقى الشعوب والحضارات
وخاصه منطقه بين المسيحيه والاسلام اللي
كانوا ميشيل بالتعايش اه منذ الف
واربعمائه سنه ولكن ابرزت سالتك عن شعور
المسيحي العربي بانه مطهر
وبخوفه ومن قلقه من الاتي بعد هذه الانظمه
الذي يتهم بانه
والى لها كما يحصل في سوريا مثلا ما رايك
نعم اه ال الانسان المسيحي هو مثل اي
انسان يعني له شعور وله كرامه وهو يرفض
القتل ويرفض الموت ويرفض الذبح ويرفض
الارهاب ويرفض العنف لانه ينادي بالسلام
والسلام الحقيقي الذي هو الاستسلام الى
الله ومن هنا ايضا اه كلمه الاسلام اي ان
ي اه اسلم ذاتي الى الله انا استسلم له
هذا هو الاسلام
الحقيقي والاسلام المعتدل الذي يحافظ على
الاخر كما المسيح ايضا المسيح الحقيقي هو
الذي يحافظ على الاخر على المسلم الاخر
لانه بيشوفوا
بالانسانيه وخير بالمحبه وبال بال بال بال
كرامه فاذن المسيحيه مهما من اي مصدر اتى
العنف من اي مكان تدين هذا الا تدين هذا
ال العنف وتنادي بالسلام و و و بالمحبه اه
هلا اه عالاكيد المسيح قال لنا اه انه سوف
اه منطق هارون
واذا اطهر وكم في هذه المدينه ان يذهبوا
الى مدينه اخرى اه لكن اه هيذا اه هيذا
شيء اه هيذا شيء لانه حتى يستتب السلام اه
يجب انه الانسان ان يعطي ذاته كما المسيح
اعطى ذاته ومات من اجل الاخرين ومن اجل
حياه الاخرين ومن اجل ان يبقى الاخرين
اعطى ذاته والمسيحيين لما ب عم يعطوا
زيتون ويتحملوا الانف والموت هني كمان
بيكونوا عم بيساهم وا بانه اه ما اخوتنا
الاسلام يعملوا حضاره مسيحيه اسلاميه
بتنادي بالمحبه
وهي ضد ال ضد الارهاب ساعود اليك سيد خليل
جهشان القول ان يعني الحديث الان متنام
جدا عن ال المسيحيين العرب ووضعهم يوسف
بالماساوي وتناقص اعداء اعدادهم علمنا
المشكله بدات منذ زمن بعيد وربما اه
فلسطين هي اكبر دليل على ذلك والعصابات
الصهيونيه التي دمرت الكنائس اه قبل اي
شيء هجره المسيحيين الفلسطينيين
ما الذي يمكن ان تضيفه بهذا الشان على
الدور الاسرائيلي الصهيوني في تهجير
المسيحيين العرب من هذه المنطقه
اه اولا دعيني اختلف قليلا اه مع ال ابي
خليل اه بخصوص ما ذكره بالنسبه ل مصطلح اه
الاقليات انا ليس لدي مشكله بان
ينعت اه ال ال المسيحي العربي بانه اقليه
لان كلمه اقليه اليوم في العصر الحديث لا
تنتقص من حقوق اه هذه ال ال الاقليات ان
كنا نعيش اه في دوله حضاريه دوله
ديمقراطيه دوله تحترم الحقوق المدنيه
لجميع مواطنيها اه المشكله ان هذه اه ال
ال الحقوق او هذه الشروط غير متاحه في
جميع انحاء العالم العربي ولكن في نفس
الوقت مازالت اسر انه من المهم جدا للمسيح
العربي ان يقبل بانه هو في الواقع اقليه
هذا لا ينتقص من قيمته ولا يجعل منه مواطن
من درجه ثانيه
اه نحن في امريكا على سبيل المثال للعرب
الامريكيين نحن ايضا اقليه هنا في
الولايات المتحده في مجتمع اه عرقي اه اه
غير متجانس فيه اقليات اه من جميع انحاء
العالم فلماذا يعني علينا كعرب ان لا نقبل
بالواقع هذه نقطه بالنسبه لاسرائيل طبعا
من المهم جدا ان نعترف ان اسرائيل كفكره
منذ بدايتها كدوله لليهود دوله اليهود في
العالم اه منذ بدايه الحركه الصهيونيه اه
في القرن التاسع عشر هي بالاساس فكره
طائفيه فكره عنصريه ومنذ انشاء
دوله اسرائيل خصوصا في بدايه الخمسينات اه
على سبيل المثال في مذكرات موشى شريط اه
ال التي يعني تكلم بصراحه في هذه المذكره
كوزير خارجيه و كرئيس حكومه سابق اه تحدث
بصراحه عن ضروره ان تقوم اسرائيل بنشر
الفكر الطائفي و تقسيم المنطقه الى دويلات
طائفيه من اجل اولا تبرير الكيان الصهيوني
في فلسطين
ثانيا اه من اجل السيطره على المنطقه لانه
كما قال اه سيك سيكون ال الوضع اسهل على
اسرائيل ان تسيطر على المنطقه اذا كانت
مقسمه الى دويلات صغيره اه طائفيه فهي سعت
اذن منذ البدايه الى تكريس هذا ال الفكر
الطائفي وشجعت كلما انقسم اه العالم
العربي او تشرذم وادى ذلك الى انقسامات
طائفيه استفادت اسرائيل وشجعت اه هذه
الطيار فهذا ليس بعامل جديد اه وطبعا اه
لوم اسرائيل بهذا الخصوص لا يعفي ايضا اه
اه ال العرب ان كان الحركات القوميه او
الحركات الاسلاميه اه من اه في الواقع
يعني اه
عدم اه معارضه هذه الفكره لانه طبعا
اسرائيل لا تفرض علينا كعرب ان ننجر الى
هذا الفكر الطائفي فانت ما قد سقطنا في
هذا المستنقع فهذا من صنع ايدينا ويجب
علينا ايضا اه ان نتحمل مسؤوليه اه اه اه
هذه ال ال التشرذم اتو هذه الانقسامات
الطائفيه التي نعاني منها اليوم ولا يكفي
ان لمها على اسرائيل بالرغم من وجود هناك
طبعا اه له مبرراته ساعود اليك ما اذا
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده مدى قدره المنطقه
على تحقيق التعايش في المستقبل نرجو ان
تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش اوضاع المسيحيين في العالم العربي
اب رشيد المسيحيون متهمون اما بالتقوقع او
بالاستقواء بالخارج
او بالتماهي مع انظمه مستبده وغير عادله
كيف يمكن الرد على هذه التهمه اه
اتهام اعتقد
[موسيقى]
لان المسيحيين يعني كشعب اه برهنوا خلال
اه
الالف واربعمائه سنه من تاييد
فعلا عن جداره بال بهذا العيش والحياه
الواحده والمكمله اه اه لا يمكن انه يكون
في اه سياسيين او بعض الانظمه او بعض
الزعماء يا اللي احتموا بالخارج لمصالح
خاصه و و ضيقه وماديه لكن اذا شفنا الشعب
على الارض اه خاصه بلبنان منشوف بكل
القضايا اللي فيها اه المسيحيين والمسلمين
عم بيعيشوا مع
بمحبه وفاء في الزواج المختلط في المشاركه
بالحياه اليوميه ان كان عند الاسلام او
عند ال ال ال المسيحيين
انا لا اعتقد انه اه نحن نست قوي بان نكون
معا هايدي هو قوتنا لانه ايد وحده ما
بتسافر بنا حققنا بها المشرق اسلام
ومسيحيه ها معا سويه نبني حضاره المحبه
ولبنان هو نموذج
من الذي يشجع على الفرقه بين المسيحيين
والمسلمين في المشرق العربي ومن الذي يشجع
اعمالك خطف المطرانين في سوريا برايك
اه نعم اه هني ال ال ال المصالح الضيقه
واستعمال اه الدين وتحويل الدين
واه استعمال الدين اه
كوسيله
للربح و وال وال والانظمه اللي هي فيها
قمعيه
والانظمه اللي هي بتع بتعمل
اه على ذوقه باستعمال الدين وهي شيء عن
الاسلام اه هودي يستفيدوا من امن مطر ان
ينعم ينشروا اه كلمه المحبه بين ال ال ال
بين المسيحيين وبين الاسلام و هني اللي عم
ينشروا ال الوحده ف اه
عدو عدو المحبه و عدو الاسلام
والمسيحيه هو اللي استعمل اشخاص وخطفوها
المطران وانا بها المناسبه بما انه نحنا
اه هوني ب اه تلفزيون قطري انا ادهشني
ممنون من سمو امير قطر يلي اولا اه ساهم
مساهمه مباشره ب اطلاق المخطوفين
اللبنانيين
امير قطر ما ما نظر اه الى اه ها الاشخاص
الا كاشخاص من الناحيه ال الانسانيه ولا
ننظر الى اه يذهبون نظر لانك اسلام وساهم
ب بتحرير هذا هو مثال ال المسلم الحقيقي
لانه عم بيساهم بتحرير الانسان هو عم
بيساهم بحضاره المحبه وكمان اه بذكر ما
قطر لما كانت حكيته عن اسرائيل اسرائيل
احتلت لبنان لسنين عديده اكثر من خمسه
وعشرين سنه
وضربت الجنوب مين كان اللي عم يجي اه
يصلح البيوت والكنائس والمعابد
والا ديار اه قطر ساهمت كثير بها المجال
لانه طلعت للبنان كان لبنان كشعب ما ميزت
بين مسلم ومسيحي وهذا هو المسلم الحقيقي
اللي بينظر المسيحي هو انسان بيقول انه
انا بدي تعيش معه واغتنى في كذلك المسيحي
هو بيهتم من المسلمين كما المسلم اللي هو
سيد خليل جهشان ما تسمى بالاصوليه والتطرف
والتكفير الى اي حد يلتقي مع ما ذكرته من
هدف اسرائيلي بتفريق المنطقه من مسيحييها
يعني تلتقي هنا ال الاصوليه مع الصهيونيه
عندما تضطهد المسيحيين
اه لا شك ان انتشار ال الفكر الاصولي اه
الذي ينكر اه الطرف الاخر ولا يعترف
بالطرف الاخر قد ساهم في هذه المشكله
ويلتقي بالاساس مع اضطهاد المسيحيين من اه
دول مختلفه ليس فقط
اسرائيل اه ولكن اه يعني في في نفس الوقت
اه هذه المشكله هي مشكله اجتماعيه اكثر
مما هي مشكله سياسيه اه الابر شيء طبعا و
رجل دين ويتكلم
بمصطلحات المحبه والوفاق انا مجرد محلل
سياسي اه اتكلم من من منطلق اخر يعني ال
المشكله كما اراها اه بصراحه اه تكمن في
مفهوم اه العرب كل المسيحيين والمسلمين
لقضيه ال الحياه المشتركه يعني عندما
نتكلم عن تاريخنا اه اه بالنسبه لل حياه
المشتركه المسيحيين والمسلمين بصراحه هذا
المفهوم منقوص ولا ينطبق اليوم وهو غير
كافي على الحياه في القرن الحادي والعشرين
يعني ان كنا قد اتفقنا قبل الف سنه هذا لا
يعني اننا سنتا في كل يوم ما هو مطلوب
اليوم كما قيل في بعض المحاضرات اه
والخطابات في هذا المؤتمر الهام المطلوب
اه حياه مشتركه على اسس جديده حياه مشتركه
تسمح اولا الاعتراف بالاخر حياه مشتركه
تعترف بحقوق الاخر تعترف بالحقوق المدنيه
الحكومه الدينيه للاخر و يحكمها ال يحكمها
القانون لوحده والشرعيه اه تنجم من
في الواقع يعني من من اراده ال المواطن من
اراده الشعب فكل هذه الايجابيه التي
مازالت غائبه عن الكثير
يعني هناك في المؤتمر اشارت الى ضروره
مشاركه المسيحيين في القرار السياسي الى
ضروره اشراك الاقباط في مصر ال ال
المسيحيين في العراق في الاردن في سوريا
كيف السبيل لتحقيق هذه الشراكه الحقيقيه
على قدم المساواه بين المواطن مهما كان
دينه في دولنا العربيه
اه اختي العزيزه هذا غير ممكن في غياب
الديمقراطيه المطلوب ليس مشاركه المواطن
العربي المسيحي كمسيحي في صنع القرار انما
مشاركه كمواطن فاذا كان المواطن العربي
غير مدعو غير مسموح له بان يشارك رجل
وامراه كانسان اه في اه اتخاذ القرار في
حياته اليوميه
وفي ال ال العمليه السياسيه في بلده لم
يصبح للاقليات اه اه مثل هذه الحقوق واذا
منحت هذه الحقوق للاقليات لانها اقليات
فلن تكون مضمونه عندها س تتهم هذه
الاقليات كما اشرت انت في العديد من
سؤالات اليوم انه هل هناك نوع من ال
الاختباء من قبل الاقليات المسيحيه في ظل
الانظمه الشموليه لانها منحتها هذه
الحمايه وهذه الحقوق ولكن لو منحتها هذه
الحمايه وهذه الحكومه كمواطنين عاديين في
الاهل لما توصلنا الى هذه النقطه
شكرا جزيلا لك خليل جهشان الخبير في شؤون
الجاليات العربيه في امريكا وايضا اشكر
الدكتور رشيد ابو خليل استاذ اللغات
الساميه والعلوم الدينيه في الجامعات
اللبنانيه و اشكر متابعتكم لهذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر ننتقل باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد فالى
اللقاء